bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
60,18 voici les titres de ce mercredi 3
mars
la maladie touche 17 % de la population
adulte en france l'obésité est mise en
lumière au travers de ces journées
mondiales qui se déroule du 4 au 6 mars
l'objectif est de changer le regard
autour de cette pathologie encore
méconnu dans cette édition le témoignage
d'une personne opérée de l'obésité est
la présidente des poids plume france
association qui oeuvre dans les yvelines
sera également notre invité ce nouvel
ensemble doit voir le jour à l'horizon
2030 à guyancourt le quartier des
savoirs se dévoile 22 hectares dont 2000
logements autour de la future gare de la
ligne 18 le 13 mars une concertation
sera lancée auprès des acteurs du projet
et des habitants elle va durer trois
heures et puis on lui prête de
nombreuses vertus la cryothérapie se
démocratise pratiqué par des sportifs de
haut niveau elle s'ouvre depuis quelques
années au grand public et nous avons pu
tester la technique dans un institut du
port marly
elle nous vous en parlions hier enfin
d'édition le port du masque est
dorénavant obligatoire partout dans les
yvelines que ce soit à l'extérieur ou
dans les lieux publics et décision du
préfet jean jacques brot pour freiner
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 par arrêté il
est également désormais interdit de
consommer de l'alcool sur la voie
publique dans l'ensemble du territoire
yvelinois en ce qui concerne le port du
masque obligatoire plusieurs exceptions
qui s'affiche être âgé de moins de 11
ans se trouvait à l'intérieur d'un
véhicule personnel ou professionnel être
cycliste ou être un usager de d'un deux
roues si la visière du casque et baissé
une personne en situation de handicap
également pour les activités sportives
enfin lors de balades en forêt seuls ou
en groupes de moins de 6 personnes
ces mesures s'appliquent jusqu'au 31
mars inclus les contrevenants s'exposent
à 135 euros damende le département des
yvelines est je vous le rappelle
toujours placé parmi les ave un
territoire en surveillance renforcée
face à l'épidémie et la préfecture l'a
également annoncé quatre nouveaux
centres de vaccination ouvrent dans les
yvelines à sartrouville
saint-cyr-l'ecole les menus les
crêpières ouverture rendue possible
grâce à la location de doses
supplémentaires de vaccins ces centres
viennent s'ajouter aux 9 déjà existants
et ouvert en janvier ce qui porte le
nombre
total à 13 sites dans le département
mais les journées mondiales de l'obésité
débute à partir de demain jeudi elle se
déroule du 4 au 6 mars pour parler de
cette maladie qui reste méconnu un mari
amis peau d'où avis à chambourcy et a
subi une opération de l'estomac c'était
il ya deux ans elle nous raconte son
parcours et ses craintes pendant cette
période de crise sanitaire michael et
demi d'euros l'a rencontré marie 42 ans
souffre d'obésité depuis son enfance il
y a deux ans et demi cette divine was a
connu une opération pour se faire
retirer les trois quarts de l'estomac
je suis suivait depuis deux ans et demi
je suis obèses depuis que je suis enfin
gto baisse depuis que je suis enfant
j'ai fait le parcours sleeve parce que
j'ai une bonne arthrose au niveau du
genou
donc j'avais un poids à perdre important
et très très vite j'ai perdu 30 kilos
donc c'est une réelle renaissants fin
parce que je peux de nouveau remarcher
au bout j'ai plus facilement et puis
c'est surtout toutes les douleurs que
j'avais dû à mon genou que je n'ai plus
en fait
aujourd'hui marie continue à être suivi
régulièrement par les spécialistes
on a des visites de quotidienne au début
tous les trois mois après ça c'est à la
six mois puis après un an avec le
chirurgien bariatrique
par contre on a toujours le suivi
nutritionniste donc là c'est tous les
mois moi j'y vais et un suivi psy qui
est hyper important après une opération
comme celle ci perdent 30 kilos en
quelques mois c'est pas rien c'est pas
anodin et qu' il faut se faire
accompagner parce que notre corps change
notre vie de famille change nos
habitudes alimentaires et autres change
en fait toute notre vie change en sur un
court temps en fait
[Musique]
du coup c'est hyperimportant vraiment le
suivi psy je m'attendais pas dans un tel
changement aussi vite et est ce que ça
allait pouvoir impliquer aussi dans ma
vie familiale et dans ma vie même
professionnel enfin pour tous en fête
depuis son opération marie a vécu
plusieurs moments difficiles et
notamment les périodes de confinement
suite à la crise sanitaire
c'était stressant pas pour moi pour ma
santé pour way pour le fait d'être à la
maison les deux du coup d'être plus à
côté de la nourriture en fait au
quotidien ça c'est plus compliqué en
fait quand on a été en baisse parce
qu'on finalement on se bat toute sa vie
contre ça c'est pas parce qu'on a été
opérée que que tout est facile et que
tout a changé en fait ça reste au
quotidien compliqué pour moi le plus dur
c'est de se battre contre tous les vieux
démons qui nous attire et qui j'ai envie
de dire qui nous attire d'un frigo ses
fins et voir pour alors que quand on est
au travail c'est plus facile parce que
bon on a pas cette envie tout le temps
en fait à ce jour mary n'est plus
considéré comme personne à risque elle
devra donc attendre pour se faire
vacciner et j'accueille en
visioconférence claudine canal bonsoir
mon parent présidente des poids plume
france l'association aide et accompagne
les personnes en situation d'obésité
elle apporte également un soutien aux
patients opérés l'obésité que ce soit
avant ou après l'intervention vous
travaillez dans les yvelines avec les
centres de poissy-saint-germain-en-laye
l'hôpital de trappes du port marly et
est aussi prochainement avec l'hôpital
de rambouillet est déjà une réaction au
sujet que l'on vient de voir marie
témoigner du moment difficile traversée
pendant cette crise sanitaire est ce que
c'est un sentiment partagé par beaucoup
de personnes qui souffrent d'obésité
alors depuis le premier confinement
effectivement il ya eu il ya eu cette
peur de regrossir de tous les patients
et toutes les personnes que l'on suivait
donc nous nous avons mis en tant
qu'association des cellules de crise et
du d'ecoute afin de justement d'aider à
passer ce cap
donc oui fait que comme disait
effectivement mari
le souci est d'aller vers le frigo et on
est tenté plus d'aller dans le
frigidaire fille le frigidaire un manque
d'activité physique aussi donc ce qui
fait que et puis annonce suivie aussi on
a eu on a eu peur d'aller à l'hôpital
pour se faire suivre faut pas oublier
que quand on est obèse et on adhère à un
parcours il faut se faire suivre avis
justement on va parler de cette maladie
obésité alors l'obésité justement l'un
des facteurs à risque face aux colis 19
selon une étude d'obésité review qui
date d'août 2020 l obésité augmenterait
de 50 % le risque de mortalité de 113 %
le risque d'hospitalisation il ya une
crainte vous le disiez face à la maladie
oui les personnes qui sont en situation
de mobilité ont très peur d'être touchée
par cette maladie parce qu'on ne sait
pas où jusqu'où on va aller et on attend
toutes les associations médicales et de
patients sont en train devrait justement
pour qu'on ait un accès aux vaccins
rapidement chose qui n'a pas été encore
accordé je pense
dernièrement je ne pense pas que pas été
encore accordé elles ne sont pas
intégrés dans la priorité de vaccination
justement vous estimez oublié
aujourd'hui par par cette stratégie de
vaccination alors des radicaux au chant
gilles la vision des gens de la personne
obèse il faut pas oublier que les obèses
ce sont des malades et des malades parce
que la maladie aux visites et justement
on a tendance à stigmatiser ou au
personnel ces personnes la soi disant
qu' on mange trop que ont fait pas son
attention à nos on bouge pas et on nous
dit maquis donc déjà dans la première
chose qu'il faut faire comprendre à
toute la population
c'est que la maladie aux visites et
c'était que l'obésité est une maladie et
qu'elle peut effectivement aussi et va y
associer plusieurs pathologies je crois
qu'on en compte 19 18
à l'heure actuelle est là qu vie dont
fait partie puisqu'il ya ce chiffre 62%
des français justement estime que
l'obésité est à vendre
avant tout due à une mauvaise
alimentation et un manque d'activité
physique
il ya des idées qu'il faut déconstruire
aujourd'hui c'est aussi pour ça qu'il ya
ces journées mondiales de l'obésité pour
déconstruire ces stéréotypes
oui c'est une journée prévention pour
dimanche prévenir la population que si
on est en situation d'obésité ou en sur
quoi parce qu'on on oublie aussi des
gens en surpoids mais c'est aussi une
grande partie de notre population
actuelle il faut que se faire prendre en
charge il ya des parcours qui sont très
très cadrée et linéaire et on peut
effectivement se faire prendre
ah ça pour cette maladie ce passé jean
charles bardon il ya des sapeurs sont
17% de la population adulte en france
inquiets concernées par l'obésité
un élève de 3e sur six également puisque
l'obésité touche aussi dès le plus jeune
âge vous le disais à partir de quel
moment faut-il s'alerter et peut-être
demandé un suivi
et bien dès qu'on voit qu'on dérape et
effectivement il faut pas avoir peur il
faut aller au 2o les associations de
patients service a effectivement assez
technique et orienter vers des prises en
charge meilleur pour cette personne se
faire soigner parce que on est malade et
je la jasse east on est malade et ça en
fait qu'il faut qu'on enlève recettes
images de tactique manisa sion les
obèses c'est pas c'est la maladie aux
visites et c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça ça fait appel à la biologie
ça peut survenir suite à un traumatisme
ça peut être effectivement aussi un
problème de vie à un moment de sa vie
ben il ya eu un basculement ça peut ça
risque que j'ai des ticos il a plein
d'autres fonctions il y en a une dizaine
que je pourrais vous citer
on n'a peut-être pas les temps de tout
citer mais c'est vraiment quelque chose
on vit avec
et comme elle le disait marie il ya une
solution peut-être la chirurgie ou pas
parce qu'il ya des personnes pour faire
cette chirurgie il faut aussi être
préparés acea a changé de vie elle s'est
très bien exprimé dans le reportage
il faut
avoir envie de changer de vie on a
compris que c'était multifactorielle et
que c'était un suivi également qu'ils
étaient à vis notamment si on a subi une
opération revient à ces journées
mondiales pour terminer avec plusieurs
choses qui sont proposés au programme
d'ailleurs il ya un challenge km contre
l'obésité qui est proposée sur le site
des journées mondiales un qui va
s'afficher saillé va s'afficher en bas
de l'écran est également votre
association qui se mobilisent pour
séjourner avec une conférence qui est à
suivre demain en visio demain jeudi
l'obésité à tout âge de la conception
d'un enfant à la vieillesse et elle
s'appelle sera suivre je le disais elle
sera à suivre en visioconférence
complètement donc on a invité des
professionnels de santé
on leur donne la parole safra animée par
deux patientes experte pour mai à
l'éducation thérapeutique qui ont
l'habitude effectivement de croiser un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont
cette maladie et les professionnels de
santé qui seront arbitrées et invités se
sont rodés gynécologues des sages femmes
il y aura des diététiciens enfin toutes
les personnes qu'on peut retrouver dans
un parcours obésité aussi d or à les
laisser faire des soins de suite de
réhabilitation cela fait aussi une
solution qui seront mis à l'honneur donc
un certain nombre d'informations seront
données lors de cette journée leur bord
de cette soirée et ça commencera à 18h
en direct sur notre page facebook mais
on retrouve toutes les informations sur
la page facebook de l'association les
poids plumes france qui s'est affiché
les horaires 18h 21h pour cette
visioconférence merci claudine canal
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous et
merci et puis rendez vous pour les
journées mondiales de l'obésité et on va
faire changer le regard de l'autre vous
êtes la présidente de l'association des
poids plume france qui intervient
notamment dans le département des
yvelines
la crise sanitaire qui est à creuser des
inégalités également chez les étudiants
près de 20% d'entre eux vivraient sous
le seuil de pauvreté en france ce
mercredi 44 étudiants de la résidence
vauban élus en cours ont reçu des colis
alimentaires grâce au secours populaire
de sacs ont été remis à chaque étudiant
inscrit avec aussi des produits
vienne à l'intérieur ait d'autres
étudiants des résidences universitaires
de bus versailles et viroflay ont
bénéficié de cette aide
un coup de pouce nécessaire pour ces
jeunes comme le précise le secrétaire du
secours populaire yvelinois au micro
d'astrid bergère sur l'ensemble de nos
bénéficiaires de la solidarité sur le
département des yvelines
on a enregistré à peu près 7000 700
personnes
il y en a plus de 1000 ce sont des 18 25
ans pas tous étudiants bien sûr mais les
jeunes en situation de précarité c'est
quand même une réalité et donc on va
aussi s'employer à la rendre peut-être
un petit peu plus visible
au total 165 étudiants ont reçu ces
colis alimentaires ils ont pu être
constitué grâce à des dons de
particuliers avec des produits du fonds
européen d'aidé aux démunis dans le
reste de l'actualité les détails du
projet du quartier des savoirs à
guyancourt connu situé sur les anciennes
friches de la société thales
cet ensemble va accueillir la future
gare de la ligne 18 des logements
également des équipements publics d'ici
le reportage de célia gars tsongo 22
hectares réaménager le futur quartier
des savoirs s'inscrit dans le projet
urbain du grand paris express
avec l'arrivée de la ligne 18 du métro
ce quartier situé au sud de la ville est
basé sur les anciennes friches de thales
accueillera environ 2000 logements mais
aussi des entreprises et des commerces
c'est une réelle opportunité pour la
ville début en cours parce que on
souhaite en faire un quartier absolument
exemplaire dans toutes ses dimensions
qu'elles soient environnementale en
termes de transition écologique en terme
de mixité fonctionnelle une mixité
sociale que le 13 mars prochain une
concertation en visioconférence sera
lancée avec tous les acteurs et
partenaires de ce projet notamment
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay mais aussi tous les
habitants qui le souhaitent
cette concertation durera environ trois
ans on va avoir des ateliers thématiques
des balades urbaines sur site enregistre
dématérialisée également où les gens
vont pouvoir exposer le leur demande
leurs questions dans ce nouveau quartier
des équipements publics viendront
s'ajouter comme un groupe scolaire un
gymnase des espaces verts et aquatiques
et aussi des locaux associatifs certains
aménagements sont d'ores et déjà établi
ce qui est déjà acté c'est l'opposé
demande la gare on le sait maintenant
c'est certain à l'angle nord-est de la
parcelle du quartier des savoirs ce qui
est acté également c'est la présence de
ce grand bois au sud de la parcelle avec
cette espace aquatique
nous allons également conserver et nous
en sommes très fiers l'allemagne au
piano le coût total de ce nouveau
quartier avoisinera la centaine de
millions d'euros
la première pierre sera posée entre 2025
et 2030 6 résout pas présent sur
l'arboretum de versailles chèvreloup
situé aux chaînés rocancourt il a
rouvert ses portes le 1er mars après
plusieurs mois de mise en sommeil sur
place des milliers d'arbres de cinq
continents a observé sur plus de 200
hectares
patrick jacques de dixmude et bixente
mais rien senti steban comme c'est jour
d'ouverture en plus profiter du beau
temps profiter des arbres un jour
ensoleillé pour les premiers visiteurs
de l'arboretum du muséum d'histoire
naturelle après presque cinq mois de
fermeture
une balade au milieu des arbres à la
découverte d'espèces du monde entier on
n'a pas de jardin du coup voilà on s'est
dit on va faire une belle balade des le
marché cheer ce petit sportif simplement
un endroit tranquille et naturel ça peut
être les gens qui viennent découvrir les
la biodiversité la faune la flore
simplement dans un espace très paisible
où il ya vraiment de l'espace pour le
visiteur on n'est pas trop serré et puis
ça peut être les jardiniers ou les
botanistes qui sont peuvent plus
spécialisés qui viennent voir des
collections particulières star de cette
réouverture le sakura autrement connu
sous le nom de cerisiers japonais plus
remarquables à voir maintenant c'est sur
les cerisiers japonais condé floraison
vraiment très éclatante alors c'est le
tout début
bientôt il y aura d'autres variétés qui
vont s'ouvrir totalement nue et des
variétés à fleurs roses vifs mais on a
des fleurs de toutes les couleurs du
blanc et rose les 2500 espèces végétales
de l'arboretum n'attire pas que les
promeneurs des visiteurs plus atypiques
profite également de l'espace quelques
chevreuils qui nous ont coupé la route
et qui se sont arrêtés en dressant leurs
oreilles donc il ya beaucoup de jazz au
delà de mammifères donc on a des
chevreuils des renards on a beaucoup
besoin comme des faisant des ronds voilà
tout avait tout autant d'espèces et puis
aussi des insectes qui viennent à
butiner les prairies fleuries qui sont
totalement sauvage elle aussi l'entrée
est payante ou sous forme d'abonnement
annuel
plusieurs parcours sont prévus ainsi
qu'une randonnée de 10 km avec comme
point d'orgue la longue allée des cèdres
bleus à deux pas du château de
versailles le dimanche l'arboretum est
également ouvert sous réserve bien sûr
de prochaines annonces de restrictions
sanitaires
il est d'ailleurs le dimanche en accès
gratuit pour tous les visiteurs
un mot de sport tony yoka était hier
mardi à saint germain en laye le boxeur
de 28 ans originaires de chanteloup les
vignes est venu s'entraîner au camp des
loges après six semaines de stage à san
francisco il prépare actuellement son
combat contre le belge joëlle tambouille
dzeko l affrontement pour le titre de
l'union européenne est programmée ce
vendredi à nantes ce sera le dixième
combat professionnel pour tony hawk a
avant de refermer ce journal parlons
cryothérapie qui se démocratise adressé
longtemps aux seuls sportifs de haut
niveau
elle s'ouvre de plus en plus au grand
public on prêterait au froid de
nombreuses vertus
astri bergère a testé est la technique
pour vous dans un institut du port marly
les images de selliers agathe son goût
aujourd'hui nous sommes à le parent
marliot crio paul on va fêter l'atrium
et rapide corps entier alors elle aurait
de nombreux bienfaits elle limiterait le
stress agirait sur les rhumatismes
améliorerait le sommeil et tonifie ray
la peau elle est plus ou moins connus
pour les sportifs mais elle devient
grand public a aujourd'hui qu'on va
tester
avant de passer dans la cabine un
entretien de 15 minutes doit être
effectuée avec une infirmière pour un
bilan de santé
alors je vous donne le bilan à remplir
mais quand donc ces les pathologies
voilà l'évaluation de la douleur de 0 à
et puis on va prendre la tension juste
avant de passer dans la machine faisait
le bras détendez vous respirez bien
tranquillement
alors une fois le questionnaire rempli
on va se changer il faut un bonnet un
masque des gants et des grosses
chaussettes
alors voilà après avoir passé
l'entretien après m'être changé je vais
rentrer dans la cabine à -85 de lépante
trois minutes
la première minute est plutôt agréable
ensuite le froid devient de plus en plus
présent tout en restant supportable on
voit des cristaux de glace formée sur la
peau
[Musique]
vient de sortir il faisait très très
froid c'était très lourd en trois
minutes mais finalement ça va on a
besoin que la peau qu'on gèle mais en
sortant c'est le soulagement
vous êtes yann à louis ii directeur du
centre
une séance de cryothérapie ce à dire
combien de temps trois minutes en tant
que tel la première séance
à peu près le tout quarante minutes
puisque on va faire un bilan et donc ce
centre il n'est pas réservé uniquement
aux sportifs non non il est réservé est
réservé à personne il est pour tous les
publics
nous faisons un accroc thérapie corps
entier qui est très connu pour la
récupération sportif mais également qui
est très long pour toutes les
pathologies en flammes à 3 donc le tout
les gens qui ont des douleurs des
inflammations des maladies chroniques
inflammatoires spondylarthrite a repris
par trop peuvent faire de la flotte
erratique
là cela c'est fini alors ici il faut
compter 29 euros pour une séance
découverte et on peut désactiver à
partir de saison avec une autorisation
parentale
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant vous
retrouver mélanie poké à la tête de son
émission le 7-8 société la thématique ce
soir l'engagement des jeunes quelles
sont leurs moteurs et belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]
momo